hey 42 here when was the last time you
did something nice weather for a friend
family member or a complete stranger and
then instantly regretted it maybe you
let a little old lady go ahead of you in
the line at Starbucks and then the
little [ __ ] goes and takes a last
cinnamon swirl which you had been
craving all morning or maybe you let
your squinting sibling borrow your
sunglasses only for them to lose them
out of the car window it's something
like this has happened to you then the
maxim no good deed goes unpunished
probably went rushing through your head
you might have even said this outlier is
a superstitious explanation for why the
universe took a massive crap on you when
all you are doing is trying to be nice
but superstitions are usually just
superstitions sure we may search
frantically for something made out of
wood to knock on to ward off bad luck
and choose to walk around ladders and
set of under them but most of us don't
do these things because we really
believe they work we just don't see the
harm and giving it a go because let's be
honest when was the last time something
bad happened to you and you can
contribute it to that time you opened an
umbrella in your kitchen my guess is
probably a zero and yet even the thought
of opening a Brawley indoors probably
gives you a little bit of anxiety the
same can't be said for doing nice things
for others you could probably run a list
off the top of your head of all the
times you've been taken advantage of
received a hostile reaction or simply
lost out all due to you trying to be a
decent person one such example of a kind
gesture epicly backfiring was when 27
year old Bobby McDonald was running for
a seat on the walton city council in
Kentucky after counting up the ballots
he and a fellow candidate had the same
number of votes each 669 to be precise
so what did the great people of Kentucky
do to resolve this great issue they
flipped a coin I [ __ ] you not
Bobby came
tails and the election was over he'd
lost all he needed was one more vote and
he would have secured that seat but it
couldn't have been helped right well not
exactly you see to understand why his
dreams of being elected to a Kentucky
City Council went south we need to go
back to the morning of the election and
more specifically his bedroom Bobby's
wife Katie is a hard-working woman she
worked nights at a local hospital as a
patient care assistant and is a students
at college on top of all this she is
also a mother raising Herman Bobby's
three kids to be expected she was bloody
knackered and when the day of the
election came for her husband seat on
the council she was having a
well-deserved lying Bobby being the
caring husband that he was just let her
sleep in Shirley one vote wouldn't
matter the rest they say is history
it's natural to point the finger at
cases like these and proclaim it was a
supernatural fate induced outcome some
energy balancing universe bollocks which
rules that good intentions should
receive negative outcomes for the giver
if he took some wooden carry a rabbit's
foot in his pockets would the day have
got any differently probably not this is
because instances like these are just a
coincidence I've covered coincidences
and the scientific reason they happen
before in another video you can find a
link to that in the description but the
reason behind why coincidences happen
all comes down to probability not fate
you can put your tarot cards down now
take the following example that shows
how we take coincidences out of context
you're at a party a small party of let's
say twenty three people you're talking
with a fellow guest and it turns out you
both share the same birthday you might
spend the rest of the party talking to
your birthday twin thinking that there
must be some reason you have crossed
paths perhaps the universe has
engineered your meeting to fulfill a
destiny be
seriously what are the chances right
well actually quite high in that room of
20 free guests there is a 50/50 chance
about two people will share the same
birthday I know there's 365 days in the
year how does that work
statistics but if you didn't know that
simple statistic probability you'd
probably think it was meant to be or
spooky and this is the problem with
coincidences when we're missing crucial
information and were not able to see the
bigger picture things that might seem
out of place will hold a greater meaning
than they actually deserve because
statistically to people showing the same
birthday at a relatively small gathering
is going to occur about one out of every
two times so let's take poor Bobby from
Kentucky sure it's rather unfortunate
that his wife's vote could have pushed
the election in his favor but that aside
the chances of a tie were already pretty
high the city of Walton at the time had
a population of around three thousand
seven hundred and with only six council
seats up for grabs it was always going
to be a close call you might also be
surprised to hear that countless
candidates all around the world have
worn by just a handful of votes or even
just one this is why your vote really
does matter it happens all the time in
fact according to a study of state and
federal elections in the u.s. between
1898 and 1992
one in every 15,000 votes cast in state
elections was the winning vote which
gave the candidate that extra majority
they needed to win
sure Bobby could have woken his wife of
that fateful day and secured her vote
but equally someone living down the
street from him might have woken up that
day and decided that they were going to
vote for his opponent of bringing it to
a tie once again under my experience
just to be on the safe side
he was probably best letting his wife
have a lion not worth it this logic
makes sense for all the unbelievably
weird occur
is that you usually hear about some
social media or perhaps have even
happened to you but I know what you're
thinking I'm not reading into things
when I'm nice it usually backfires and
unfortunately you're right researchers
at the University of Guelph discovered
that when people are highly cooperative
and generous
they attract hatred so you're not
imagining it but why does this happen it
all stems from a deep-rooted attitude of
not wanting to look bad and what's a
reliable way to look bad when someone
else does something good especially
something you wouldn't do and so of
course the only way to cover up your
insecurities is to punish that person
that's shown you up and bring them down
a peg or two but this isn't a new thing
there is evidence to suggest that this
mindset occurred during often together a
days and it obviously hasn't left us
professor path Barkley who led research
on this matter says and a lot of these
societies they defend their equal status
by bringing down someone who could
potentially lord things over everybody
else if that sounds like a fourth
process you regularly encounter whilst
at work you'd be right
the fear of someone doing better than
you is even more prevalent in
competitive environments and get this it
was found that people will still punish
the do-gooder even if it is detrimental
to themselves but why are acts of
kindness are sometimes met with somewhat
surprising hostility might be due to the
reason we're trying to be nice in the
first place when was the last time you
did something good for someone else and
didn't get something in return this
could be anything from gaining favors to
getting that warm fuzzy feeling inside
the answer is probably never but it's
okay it wasn't a trick question
doing God makes us feel good being
generous usually instills one with a
feeling of self
warmed towards our fellow man and the
sense of purpose so when you held open
the door for that young lady with the
pram what you were really looking for
was a simple smile in return an
acknowledgment of your good deed another
notch on your I'm a good human stick so
when you got a grunt and a pram wheel
over your foot you instantly regretted
wasting your time and energy so what
went wrong here to put it simply you
expected a reaction that you didn't
perceive and in a way that's your fault
that may sound harsh but hear me out
expecting a particular reaction from
someone even when you're doing something
which you consider nice is never
guaranteed even when it's something
stupidly simple such as holding a door
the receiver might have a whole host of
reasons why that gesture wasn't
appreciated maybe they had to pick up
their pace and felt rushed perhaps
they've always used the other door for
some unknown weird reason heck perhaps
they were triggered by your toxic
masculinity who the hell knows and
that's kind of the problem we don't know
no matter how hard we try it's
impossible to know how a good deed will
be received because there were always
too many variables which we are unaware
of so what we usually end up doing is
what we think is the best thing to do
because that's all we have to go on sure
you thought you'd be mr. popular giving
out full-size Snickers bars at Halloween
but to the kid who just turned up with a
severe peanut allergy
you just made his night a lot worse and
probably sends his mom on a Facebook
rounds naming and shaming you but what
about those times when we hit the nail
on the head we might do something nice
for someone like mow their front garden
give them a lift or even just offer a
shoulder to cry off but then something
happens they put in more requests again
and again before you know it that single
kind gesture has turned into a weekly
chore and your calendar is completely
filled up of a mixture of babysitting
their kids and being there
probably sounds familiar right well to
be brutally honest
there is no deep-rooted scientific axiom
here usually this is just a case of
people being general [ __ ] and taking
advantage of your generosity it happens
and it can easily make us regret being
nice in the first place
but if you constantly find yourself
being taken advantage of in this way
there's a chance it isn't just bad look
if you're an empathetic person who
usually goes that extra mile of helping
someone chances are you are a prime
target for sociopaths according to
professor Jayne McGregor and mental
health practitioner Tim McGregor very
highly empathetic people can find
themselves helping governs at the
expense of their own needs and for
individuals of this tendency the
psychopath sociopath can manipulate and
take advantage of that person by
eliciting pity and/or guilt from them
all this sounds pretty disheartening and
after all I just told you why would you
want to do something nice ever again
well there is one reason kindness might
be the secret to living a longer life
and how do we know this rabbits in 1978
dr. Robert Naren and his fellow
researchers were conducting an
experiment and a group of rabbits to
determine whether or not a high-fat diet
would impact heart health but the
results gave dr. Naren something to chew
on
as he would have had expected that all
of the rabbits in the study would have
shown a vast increase in the fatty
deposits in their small blood vessels
which usually corresponds with high
cholesterol levels
what they didn't not to the same extent
anyway about 60% of the rabbits studied
had better health outcomes than the
others but instead of abandoning the
study dr. Naren wanted to find out why
exactly these rabbits hadn't experienced
the same detrimental health effect
of the other bunnies and what he
discovered was shocking it turned out
that all of the rabbits that did well
during the experiment were all being
looked after by the same researcher and
she wasn't just feeding them she was
giving them love attention kindness they
repeated the experiment with this in
mind and the results were the same
it was a fact receiving kindness can
make you healthier but what about being
kind I don't care about other people
benefiting from my kindness
well first yes of course there are
benefits to being kind and second a
platitude is definitely not going to
help you being nice and doing good deeds
is phenomenal for one's health because
our brains love being kind and in return
they secrete an array of chemicals which
aid in our mental and physical wellness
for example when we get that warm fuzzy
glow from holding the elevator for
someone
our brains release endorphins our body's
natural pain reliever oxytocin which is
shown to lower blood pressure and
serotonin which helps our mood not bad
for pressing a button is it so the next
time you have a chance to do something
nice for someone I say do it but do it
because you want to not because you feel
you should or you want to get a certain
response and the next time you offer
someone a free coffee and they look at
you of suspicion thinking you've spat in
it or poisoned it just smile because
you've just prolonged both of your lives
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please consider supporting me
on patreon the links in the description
it really helps me to continue to make
these videos also this is your very last
chance to get your name printed in my
book stick a flag in it a thousand years
of bizarre history from britain and
beyond the deadline is the 29th of March
after that date you can still order your
copy but your name won't be able to be
printed in the book because we're
finishing things up to get it ready to
be printed so thank you the links in the
description